indianapolis is ground zero this year
for the college basketball championships
now due to cover 19 the ncaa decided to
house everything in one city
much like the nba did last year the
pandemic may also mean fewer
and smaller watch parties here are some
ideas to enjoy the 2021 championships at
home
after the college championships were
canceled last year
fans are desperately awaiting this
year's excitement
lifestyle expert kia malone has tips to
celebrate safely
turn your home into an arena decorate
with your favorite teams jerseys and
pennants maybe put
all of that around the tv where the
action is focused you can even
incorporate a little mini
indoor basketball goal so you and your
friends can replay all those exciting
moments
watching sports at home means good
finger foods and it doesn't have to be
the same old same old
chips salsa wings i mean i'm kind of
over it right why don't you level up
your snacks this year with some great
seafood items made by
cpac maybe try the butterfly shrimp as
is
or spice it up a little bit and wrap it
with some prosciutto and melted
mozzarella cheese
you can even incorporate the butterfly
shrimp into a nice fresh bruschetta with
you know crusty bread tomato and little
bit of basil you will definitely be the
talk of the town
with some great frozen seafood find
ideas for your march
game watching madness at cpac.com
there's more las vegas now after the
break we'll be right back